mind your decisions i'm presh tal walker
what is the value of the following some
burgerking
asked this problem on twitter the value
of this sum would be a promo code that
could be used for a free whopper with
any purchase to avoid spoiling the
answer I'm going to solve a slightly
different problem to illustrate the
method of how you would solve such a
problem so what is the value of the
following some- the sum from I going
from 1 to 100 of negative 1 to the power
of I multiplied by the following
quantity 5 factorial multiplied by 5 all
over 4 factorial and the entire quantity
raised to the power of 1/2 pause if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem well
get started by simplifying five
factorial over 4 factorial 5 factorial
is equal to the product of the whole
numbers from 1 to 5 and 4 factorial is
equal to the product of the whole
numbers from 1 to 4 we can get the
division of 5 factorial by 4 factorial
by dividing the second equation from the
first notice will eliminate 4 3 2 & 1 in
the product we're left with just 5 we
substitute that in and we have 5 x 5
this will be equal to 5 squared 5
squared raised to the power of 1/2 will
be equal to 5 we can then factor out the
5 we then want to evaluate the following
sum of negative 1 to the power of I
where I goes from 1 to 100 we can write
these terms out now negative 1 raised to
an odd power will be equal to negative 1
and negative 1 raised to an even power
will be equal to 1 we thus simplify the
following terms and we have an
alternating sum negative 1 plus 1 and so
on until the final pair negative 1 plus
1 so every pair of terms will actually
cancel out to be equal to 0 therefore
this entire sum will be equal to 0 so we
have negative 5 x 0 and that's of course
equal to 0 it's great to see a big
company use mathematics in its social
media promotion let me know if you see
any other companies using math in their
social media thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]